first question for men
if you like a girl if you're even
somewhat interested in a girl
you need to ask yourself this question
are you single
no i don't mean are you kind of single
seeing five people
dating somebody still kind of in a
relationship
kind of broken up kind of on again off
again kind of married
kind of divorced are you actually single
single
that means single you have nobody you
have no complications you have no
attachments
you are actually single that is the
first question
believe it or not that needs to be asked
and ladies you should be
i wonder if she asked this question when
she was 22 partying
right when she would bounce from due to
dude i wonder if she asked this question
if he was signal
when she hooked up with him 20 minutes
after meeting him
at the phone cannon party in cancun i
wonder if these questions were
were things that come across her head in
her party ears or do they only come
across
to her right now because she's hit the
epiphany phase and realize that
she needs to cash out on the sexual
marketplace and find a
good guy and you know get wifed up and
do her 2.1 kid obligation like all
tradcon women must do right
asking it because in 2020 that's a good
point somebody just put there in the
chat
when are women ever single
see women are hypergamous right so
they're always looking for the best deal
you know whatever guy is that guy at the
time
and she's lecturing you saying you
better be single if you go out with me
if you're not single you're wasting my
time guys
well when are women ever particularly
single they're
they're only you know if you haven't
again watch my channel
dive into the red pill playlist and
you'll hear me talk about many of these
tenants you know one of them is ber
fault's law
and women only stay with men and this is
universal across
uh primate species but women only stay
with men so long as they prove
themselves to be useful to women meaning
they supplicate
and feed her whims and desires and
whatever her agenda is basically at the
end of the day
it's why you know a lot of these trad
con women will
take marriage vows and say till death do
his part and sickner and poorer and
richer and
blah blah blah blah and all that sort of
stuff and that's until
things don't work out and if they don't
work out she can check out
and use the divorce machine to exit and
take access and custody of the kids and
watch money flow from him to her through
the divorce machine
and it's a pretty good deal from her you
know it's it's very low risk
high reward so you have to understand
that women always reserve the right to
change their mind at any given time this
is not
like there's no guarantee just because
uh you know she's one of these track con
women they're not immune from
you know women they're not immune from
feminism feminism is in all women to
some degree or another she just doesn't
look like a feminist
you